i know that a lot of you came here to
see if i was going to
do this on camera finally so here you go
for it for your eyes only
brownies
and ranch
[Music]
hey everybody i'm doug cameron and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
during the pandemic i became
what most people would call a michelin
star chef i got rice cakes then i would
slice up some avocado mash it up what is
it pestle and mortar i'm making that up
that sounds like a game of thrones name
mortar and pestle and i are going up to
the what's the eye of sour on that's
what it sounds like i would mash this up
and then i would put like chili flakes
and i would make sure there was always
someone there to throw it to me and then
i would layer it with the smoked salmon
do i actually do it i have to have a
portal in metal
just pretend like you're not seeing this
there we go great gorgeous so i just
mortar and pestled this guys i've had
really so much coffee and you're going
to zoom in on this it's just going to be
my shaking hand
this is glorious
oh my god
run don't walk most snacks i will be
having today are my breakfast snacks
because i have a single coming out
called
breakfast
my peripheral vision is so good you guys
i have to call my mom about that okay so
this next thing was an invention by
my father i remember this so clearly it
was a summer day and my dad brought out
a bagel with cream cheese and rainbow
sprinkles ever since then it's been a
winning combo and it's gotta be rainbow
sprinkles don't be crazy okay don't put
chocolate sprinkles that's insane and
you should be locked up if you're having
that thought but as particular as i am
about the sprinkles and the cream cheese
being plain the bagel you can have your
fun with and a blueberry bagel is the
best bagel and i don't care what anybody
has to say about that um oh [ __ ] me okay
you have fun with this you guys
i don't think i've had this since i was
like actually a little kid
[Music]
that [ __ ] heads
i can't lie to you
that holds up
wow that's good
it's like
a cream cheese danish but a blueberry
bagel the sprinkles really add something
to it i really recommend this all right
on to the next snack
thanks tim
this is about to be really bad so now we
have you know your normal everyday
american breakfast the chili cheese fry
here's the thing about this it's not
breakfast food but anything is breakfast
food if you try hard enough you know
what i mean
the amount of approval i'm getting from
the room is crazy they're all like
i'm like really leading here chili
cheese fries
are the best combination of what humans
have to offer chili cheese and fries you
got your complex carbs
you got your protein you got your
calcium and that's really all you need
take it from me body buy chili cheese
fries if you ever eat at a bowling alley
which i do mostly
you know nacho culture means you got to
go for like not the bottom because
that's not that all the fixings haven't
reached the bottom but but like right in
the middle and like a little bit off to
the side where you get all the good
ingredients and if you're gonna get a
bite you gotta get everything on it
yeah this is a delicacy
it's really good
all right next snack
brian and tim are preparing
the next snack you'll never meet them
but just know that they're good people
tim
you know what i said before about tim
being a good person we didn't rehearse
this but we should have
this next snack is one of my all-time
favorites and uh i know you're thinking
sauces for chips and you would be
correct for the most part except for the
fact that it is also for peppers this is
a really good alternative to chips
because i love salsa i love spice
peppers are crunchy they're full of
vitamin c and they're good for your skin
barrier and your telomeres and your
fluffy hippocampus so that we stay
cognitive as we get older you know the
important things look it's this it's
this [ __ ] easy watch this and i will
be taking this also home with me
um oh my god
this is not an advertisement but it
could be mild i love that they bought me
a salsa they were like she's
she's a mild [ __ ]
and they were wrong and brian we're
gonna talk about that later
i know that a lot of you came here to
see if i was going to
do this on camera finally
it has been years and i'm finally
speaking out against all of the the
onslaught of hate
that i've gotten for this choice so here
you go for it for your eyes only this is
uh
brownies
and ranch
[Music]
exceptional i have to defend this
listen this was an accident i used to
have this little mermaid plate when i
was seven and i had brownies and i had a
caesar salad with ranch and a little bit
of ranch
went from the salad onto the brownie and
i was like a kid and i didn't realize
and then i stumbled upon
the greatest discovery
um
i don't know some ancient artifact that
i'm not educated enough to know what
it's called here's the thing though
it's been years since i verified that
this is good
i said it one time in an interview and
it went everywhere i really actually
feel like i'm like on trial right now i
was like
i'm so [ __ ]
um all right here we go we're gonna find
out if i actually stand behind this or
not
[Music]
hmm
that
is so [ __ ] good
and you are
all about to eat it eat it and eat it
there you have it those are my favorite
snacks when you're done roasting me in
the comments
check out my new film vengeance in
theaters july 29th and watch out for my
new single breakfast i love you
[Music]
you